hi i'm sorry hi i'm anka i am a video
producer from buzzfeed new york so i was
watching this video on bring me of this
little shop where they make these super
cute character macarons i love macarons
and i love cute stuff so i flew all the
way from new york to the oc to learn how
to make these macarons from leanne the
owner of the shop so here we are at
honey and butter
[Music]
so we're going to be making red pandas
today because england love bears we're
going to do two heads two full bodies
and then the last one we're going to do
a challenge by making a regular panda
right on top of a red panda so let's get
started
[Music]
think we're done with my tray so let's
go to you
take a good look at this now
because mine will not look like this
no i i think um you would do really good
especially if i'm right behind you i was
like no no
shall we yeah watch out this is
stripping
already already i messed up oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god okay there
you go so you gotta start right away
okay so like this
yep
squeeze it
wow that's a distorted looking face
how's that look hopefully it'll settle
once you tap it
okay now we're gonna apply the ears
first you gotta trim the bag so like
here
is it too small no it looks fine
wow
how wide does mine look like it's really
struggling if you want to do it all in
one go be confident with your battered
deposit
huh
a lot of batter oh just like that okay
got it
oh my goodness
got this i feel so sorry
i want to say it's like botox but i
don't think i should say that it's
battery injection so about a third way
up and right in the middle of the face
you're going to do this now
okay
is that enough yep that's good
my hands are shaking
i think that looks a little bit better
oh yeah but these guys are supposed to
be full body oh you can lay it over no i
think we can lay it over okay this is
not easy at all did i cover this oh that
tip might be a little bit big
there you go this is like a concealer oh
yeah
okay cool all right covering this yeah
[Music]
next is we're gonna do the eyes i'm
scared
oh no
i pandas i feel like okay
see what i did there
okay
triangle for the nose
[Music]
nope nope i gave him a button i can't
talk and like do this at the same time
i'm so scared no no no no no no
let's give this some claws
oh yeah yeah
no
he just stuck his paw in mud or
something right
okay so we're gonna do
the face
and which one am i supposed to be
squeezing it your right hand and your
left hand is used to guide it oh oh
maybe that's why because this is like
second nature to me i think you were
squeezing with both hands and then i was
squeezing with my left hand yeah
yeah squeeze with just your right hand
this hand is used to guide but okay so
wherever your tip is moving you should
guide it and there you go
[Music]
all right all right did i do it nice
work looks great at least i recognize it
still i was worried it would just be
like a lovely
blob do you want to make these see how
they turned out
yes i'm excited
bye bye babies
yay
very important
i think this shop is like super cute
like it's not just the macarons but like
the whole display of things like the
whole decoration i really want to know
like how do you come up with this
concept like this idea so this whole
shop basically is my entire personality
injected into it yeah everything you see
here from the macarons to all the tsum
tsum all the merchandise and they shell
and the drink sleeves as well
a reflection of who we are and
macarons is something i knew i
definitely wanted to do since i was
doing it as a hobby and it brought me a
lot of joy so i just continue doing that
and then maybe i can try
selling it to see how it would be and
you know i dropped everything and i
focus on just doing the small business i
enlisted the help of my mom to help
clean i know moms are the best and then
my family eventually came to help and
here we are
so these are done baking and what you
want to look for is in a good bake
you're going to have a cookie
with a flat bottom like this
pretty good
[Music]
looking great
somebody at the bottom maybe
didn't bake so well but these guys look
great
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a cost for celebration every
time they come out so clean and pretty
like this it's like a happy dance so you
want to go as liberal as possible
and
cover it but not so much that it oozes
outside
so you can sandwich it right in the
middle just like that so you could see
the filling but it's not
[Applause]
okay okay okay now you tried all right
this is the
berries and there's berries enchanted
berries
that
that good yep that's good
so like yeah that
that's good okay
dunk it in
all right
gently press it
get all that cereal in there
that looks good
okay more and more filling more
more filling
fill it up a little bit on top
more more
oil
they are done
[Applause]
[Music]
uh we're gonna do a little comparison
here who do you think did better don't
answer that question
but i mean i'm just happy that mine is
at least recognizable i just want to eat
it
mine looks like his face melted a little
bit but you know still a red panda
cheers
oh man you went straight for the baby
panda i'm going to save the baby panda
in the middle
it's soft on the inside
and the buttercream is melty it's like
chewy on the inside but it's slightly
hard on the outside which is crispy on
the outside which is what you want wait
but they're so cute i'm like so torn but
i can't stop eating it so
whatever
so
how do you think i performed did i do
okay i think you did really well the
question is will you be able to do this
by yourself at home
you know
i think
maybe
but like one i think i need you here to
kind of guide me a little bit and then
two i don't know how to make the batter
like i feel like the batter is the
hardest part so
the answer is no
i think we should do episode two when
she comes back and we teach her better
so i can do everything at home i am down
i am down but like what time do i have
to come to make the batter again
as early as you can 4am
yeah okay no
thank you thank you thank
you come get your own cute macarons